well you've been in LA for four years
how many of those years have you spent
in acting class is being onset
considered an acting class if it's not
then none I've never been to an acting
class in LA I just came here and started
working and I couldn't afford acting
classes so I figured well I'm just gonna
work and I'll learn on set I fall on my
ass and making mistakes and asking DPS
what can I do better and ask in the
gaffer how can I find my light and ask
in the director you know what did I do
wrong and so that's been my education it
probably took me 20 or 30 projects to
really figure out what I was doing wrong
and tried to start to do it right if I'd
had the money I would have gone to
classes but instead I just went to work
it seems like there's so many people
that are very religious about going to
their acting class once twice a week and
and then they go out for coffee
afterward and it's this big group sort
of communal thing do you think a lot of
that is a nice social outlet but maybe
it's not beneficial well Biman said it's
my social outlet I'm a hermit otherwise
but I try to do about a movie a month
and that's my time to be social and you
know hang around craft services and talk
to people but also to learn about my
craft to learn something from every
single role so I guess that's me do in
the actual movies is my acting class
which is a little bit dangerous because
what if you're bad and I have been but
yeah again it's just financially you
know I never had the money to spend on
the acting classes so I just decided
well I'm just gonna start doing movies
and learning as I go what about someone
else who comes to LA and they
money for all of the gurus and that the
workshops and all these different things
that are constantly marketed to yeah I
know I don't have the money for those
things so what do they do they go on
YouTube they Google videos they work go
to work go to work it's what you're here
for go to work you can't tell me that in
Los Angeles you can't find work you
cannot tell me that somewhere in this
city right now there's not someone who
will ask you to be a part of their
project it may not be paid and if it
pays it may not be much but if you're
just starting out that's what you do go
to work don't moon about it don't think
about it go to work get your ass on set
get in front of a camera even if you
think you're not ready to get in front
of a camera because that camera will
teach you it will be your teacher don't
watch movies during the afternoon in
your apartment what's that
don't watch movies during the afternoon
in your apartment why watch a movie when
you can be in a movie which do you learn
more from B end the movie
you